jeudi dernier le jour de la terre nous a
rappelé l'autre grand problème qui
menace l'humanité
les changements climatiques est aussi
que les gaz à effet de serre et
contribue largement
comme le co2 bien sûr mais aussi le
méthane dont l'effet est important et
site à lui qu'une jeune entreprise
canadienne a choisi de s'attaquer
du méthane il s'en échappe des mines de
charbon des dépotoirs et même des
animaux d'élevage
le méthane s'accumulent dans
l'atmosphère bouleverse le climat son
effet de serre est beaucoup plus
puissant que celui du co2 dans les
industries pétrolières et dans plusieurs
autres industries le méthane est le
problème principal c'est pour ça
vraiment qu'il faut le format de trouver
il ne contrôlait pour le régime les
satellites canadiens ont désormais
l'oeil cet ennemi invisible
de ces janvier dernier à calgary une
équipe de gea gesat nous invite à bord
d'un petit avion
c'est la meilleure façon de voir en
action la technologie qui est à bord de
leur satellite
il s'agit en gros de télescopes mais qui
pointe vers le sol
l'instrument va braquer son regard sur
une usine de gaz naturel est un site
d'enfouissement de sources potentielles
de méthane parmi de nombreux autres le
méthane pour mémoire c'est bien de
source naturelle
il faut se souvenir que le méthane c'est
quand même un gaz qui est produit par
toutes sortes de différentes sources
comme des marécages comme des
compositions de végétation dans l'eau
mais aussi évidemment c'est bien de
sources industrielles
alors les sources principales
industriels sont les pétrolières
certainement les mines de charbon et en
os dans l'ouest et les sites
d'enfouissement
il y en a qui sont mieux géré que
d'autres disons l'objectif de stéphane
germain s'était créé un satellite
capable de distinguer entre elles les
différentes sources de méthane les bons
et les moins bons joueurs c'est ce qu'on
a fait que différents qui est vraiment
innovant si on est les premiers au monde
qui peuvent l'utiliser satellite pour
mesurer des émissions provenant de sites
individuels
jusqu'à tout récemment les seuls
satellite à surveiller les
concentrations mettant dans l'air
étaient ceux des agences spatiales
notamment de l'europe
il récolte des données à grande échelle
certaines places comme par exemple au
bangladesh à partir desquels ga gesat a
conçu cette carte interactive destinée
au public
si on se retourne maintenant en amérique
du nord et on va voir le contraste est
intéressant c'était sévère quand même
alors c'est une bonne nouvelle on a
quand même quelques petits défis ça
dépend encore des saisons mais un sud
ouest de l'ontario avec plus de
production industrielle avec des
raffineries dans le coin de saint aignan
le pétrole le gaz et le charbon font une
fois de plus partie des coupables
parce qu'en plus d'émettre du co2 quand
on les brûle il ya du méthane qui
s'échappent canton les extraits et qu'on
les transporte et le méthane se comporte
très différemment du co2 quand on émet
une tonne de co2 l'impact sur le climat
est modéré mais le co2 restent longtemps
dans l'atmosphère avec le méthane c'est
tout le contraire
son impact est gigantesque et même si je
diminue rapidement en quelques années à
peine
le méthane à 36 fois plus d'impact sur
le climat que le co2 en un site complet
le bon côté c'est qu'en réduisant les
fuites de méthane
l'effet est immédiat à condition de
savoir exactement d'où elles viennent
mais maintenant si on descend aux états
unis leur coin ici on est sur la
frontière du nouveau mexique et du texas
il ya beaucoup de production de pétrole
de gaz de schiste et on trouve souvent
des émissions x sont élevés de méthane
ici il y à des puits à perte de vue et
ils sont trop près les uns des autres
pour que les satellites traditionnel
puisse savoir lequel émettent du méthane
c'est ce que permet de faire le
satellite de gea gesat qui a été
développée testés et assemblés au canada
[Musique]
alors pour nous les deux au défi en pas
réfugié un défi mais les premiers défis
c'était la spectroscopie vraiment de
trouver un instrument qui peut être
sensible à la présence du gaz
un tel point qu'on peut le mesurer avec
une très haute résolution au sol et
deuxièmement de mettre tout ça dans un
très petit instrument qui peut ensuite
être un satellite de la taille d'un faux
micro
l'optique a été confiée à l'équipe d'à
bébé à québec qui se spécialise dans les
instruments de détection
le coeur du système c'est ce
spectromètre
ils analysent la lumière du soleil qui
rebondit sur le sol il en fait un arc en
ciel de longueur d'onde
si la lumière traverse du méthane
certaine longueur d'onde seront bloqués
c'est ce qui permet de détecter et plus
il ya de méthane plus ces longueurs
d'onde s'efface ce qui donne une idée de
la concentration
on peut donc dans un premier temps
identifier les fuites dont l'attention
se tourne plutôt vers un autre tout
petit con pour livrer des données à nos
clients certaines installations va avoir
des petits triangles rouge et ça ça veut
dire qu'on a trouvé un panache ou une
émission basse dans cet endroit là et on
peut calculer la quantité totale qui
était mise sur cette image chaque pixel
couvre environ 25 mètres par 25 m au sol
le capteur utilisé compte un million de
pixels et pour chacun on peut calculer
la concentration de méthane
alors c'est ça qui nous permet
maintenant d'avoir dans le champ du
l'ensemble de l'année des concentrations
de méthane par personne alors si on a
une source au rang des concentrations
élevées à côté de la source et avec le
vent on trouve le panache qui nous
permet ensuite ensuite de quantifier le
taux d'émission à la source mais il y a
tellement de 7 à surveiller que seul
satellite ne suffit pas
afghans employés fin janvier j'ai ag sap
a lancé hugo le troisième de ce qui sera
bientôt une flotte d'une dizaine de
satellites
les nouveaux sont dix fois plus sensible
que le tout premier qui a servi de test
ça permet de détecter des fuites de
moindre envergure
celle qui ensemble constituent la
majorité des émissions de méthane
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment rendu une
zone beaucoup plus opérationnels pour
nos clients alors on parle pas
nécessairement de fuite dimanche on
parle plutôt de fuite qui arrive parce
qu'à tous les jours opérationnelles
qu'ils veulent trouver pour quelques
s'est adressée
[Musique]
le même instrument est encore plus
sensible et chrissy quand il est plus
près du sol comme sous un avion celui
utilisé à calgary revenait d'ailleurs
d'une tournée d'inspection aux états
unis on voit maintenant une installation
une seule installation et on voit avec
mes résolutions de moins d'un mètre même
quel équipement dans l'installation une
chute et on voit que dans ce cas ici
deux émissions et de deux équipements
différents sur le site
alors ça ça donne une impression très
précises aux opérateurs pour qu'ils
puissent même préparé leur colmatage si
la réparation est assez simple ça peut
être rentable le colmater une fuite pour
récupérer le méthane parce qu'après tout
c'est du gaz naturel sans un prix si le
problème est plus coûteux à corriger la
motivation peut venir des gouvernements
ou même des investisseurs qui
s'intéressent à la cote verte d'une
entreprise là dessus chaque pays a sa
réalité dans l'ancienne union soviétique
comme au turkménistan certains gazoducs
sont vieillissants et fuit abondamment
en milieu tropical la végétation qui se
décompose dans les bassins
hydroélectriques génère du méthane les
rizières en aimait aussi beaucoup et les
solutions ne sont pas toujours évidentes
gs gesat aimerait s'attaquer un jour où
co2 et à d'autres polluants
mais pour l'instant elle se concentre
sur le méthane un bon filon pour
l'entreprise bien sûr mais aussi pour la
science et pour le climat